this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode Jonathan is taking a
look at the alternate timeline Weaponry
of the Wolfenstein franchise thing about
converting a firearm to a directed
energy weapon is well it's essentially
like converting a water pistol into a
machine gun you know you've got all some
of the same basic ergonomics but that's
it nothing else is going to be carried
over to the finished gun if there are
any other games guns and mechanics you
guys want to see Jonathan break down let
us know in the comment section below and
for something a little bit different
make sure to check out our new series
Mind Games a show that explores the
psychological impact of gaming from our
relationship with loot boxes to the
psychology behind horror games right
time to check out the guns of
Wolfenstein
all right seems like a good place to
start the Luger or something close to
the Luger anyway they were still in the
40s at this point and we have something
not massively accurate for the Luger
it's recognizably a Lugo in terms of its
silhouette not one thing on it is
correct trigger guard very very chunky
we do have the interesting Luger Half
Moon trigger I'm not sure everyone's
aware of the toggle is action is
basically there but all the shapes are
different the notably the ears as it
were the knurled lugs that you grasped
to actually operate the weapon they look
more like car wheels on this The Twist
on Twist Off suppressor is not a thing
what you can't do is just you know quick
detach that's not a system that existed
and then even stuff like this
distinctive shape of the frame is there
but there's an extra weird shaped insert
and various screw looking features that
are just not on the real gun even the
grip has two weird well one thing I
can't see the actual magazine cache that
seems to have slipped across and become
part of the grip it's like a Luger
created by someone who's sore Luger once
so that's not being too much but then
the whole game is highly stylized a
reboot of a two and a half D FPS from
1992. so I don't think we can be too
exacting I'm just here to point out
interesting details
so moving on within this game to the
futuristic pistol derived from the Luger
or inspired by the Luger which is not
something that happened in real life in
real life this became
well completely replaced by the P38 and
its derivatives which is a completely
different design much simplified cheaper
to make less complicated as well and
therefore more reliable in the long run
very although a similar kind of
silhouette a very different pistol what
they didn't do is take the iconic pistol
and develop it onwards now that that
decision had already been taken by well
strangely enough 1938 so alternate
timeline I know ultimate alternate
timeline I cannot see the Luger getting
so radically evolved into some sort of
weird machine pistol I think it is in
this it seems to fire burst or even if
it was just a normal pistol it's just
not something you do but in pop culture
logic you know your iconic Nazi pistol
keeping that and making it look more
sort of sci-fi in a parallel 1960s where
they've been investing heavily in all
sorts of Technology it makes a strange
kind of sense
foreign
next one along looks to it's not quite
the same design that the rear of the
frame has changed and some of the
detailing has changed but it's pretty
close I think it's one of those sequel
guns where I don't think we're supposed
to spot the differences although having
said that the little red highlights from
the previous version are now yellow so I
don't know if that's significant I
haven't played New Colossus I've only
played new order it still gives us that
Luger in space Vibe a little bit more
streamlined a bit shorter too by the
look of it maybe that's my imagination
and funnily enough when you put the
little skinny suppressor on it it's
still
brings you back to this iconic sort of
silhouette
so this very elaborate alternate reality
Thompson which is basically what we're
looking at sheet metal and unnecessarily
carved bits of wood and it's it's sort
of like a Thompson but not really it's I
think it speaks to the artistically LED
design process of the weapons in this
game that for a very short part of the
game we have a totally different
Thompson you know they could have got
one from an asset Library they could
have re-revamped one from the previous
game maybe or just made a straighter
1928 Thompson gun but they didn't do
that they just went nope we're going to
design a gun that you in this case you
won't even ever see in the rest of the
game from scratch that's radically
different to the real one and you know
what I can't really complain about that
I will notice it I will comment on it
but that's their choice
all right
I've um pulled out not necessarily the
emotional support just don't give out
just a stone giver but uh because that's
essentially what we're looking at here
but it's a weird parallel universe mp44
or sdg sdg44 this one's marked uh mp44
but needless to say perhaps this thing
doesn't really look a whole lot like the
thing on screen
um what I'm looking at looks more like I
don't know a comic book version of a
strong River and maybe that's okay
because Wolfenstein really is inspired
by Comics based on wartime adventure and
Comics very rarely bother to get guns
right or if they do they stretch
proportions they change features so this
feels like a increasingly these games
feel like a conscious effort to do their
take on that design so the big standout
here are the the huge housings that are
either side and forward of the bus stop
but behind the magazine well you can see
them in the first person view you can
see them very clearly looking down at
this gun on the ground they're not
inspired by anything on the real gun at
all or anything else I can think of
they're there purely for design purposes
the grip frame is somewhat similar and
has the the wooden grip panels we've got
a wooden butt stock we have a metal
handguard so we have that overall feel
of a Stone River they've moved the rear
sight from its fairly distinctive
position here similar to where it would
end up on the on the Kalashnikov as well
to back here on top of the receiver and
the difference is go go on
foreign
rate of fire is pretty spot on this
thing chugs big time I've been fortunate
enough to fire one it's a very similar
rate of fire even the sound is actually
pretty pretty close to my recollection I
have unfairly paused this bang on a Case
ejection uh pleased to say that the
primer is struck for those of us that
care however the whole cartridge case
has a decidedly hexagonal look to it
this is a relatively low poly cartridge
case that's coming out of the gun hardly
a problem it flies out you're not going
to see it unless you pause and stare at
the screen then why would you do that
only if a video game review company was
was asking you to do it on camera
foreign
view a lot of the conventional firearms
in these games are very busy they look
cool but there are features there that
don't appear to have any practical
function and would be a real pain and a
lot of cost to machine and and really
just aren't doing anything with sci-fi
stuff you can kind of hand wave away
that sort of design but um here we have
to just accept that the parallel
universe Nazis have over designed but
they've really gone to town with this
and it would make it very heavy compared
to what it needs to be because what it
needs to be is this which is very very
spelled actually very very slim
foreign
towards I think
Maybe
we are we have a nod to the Heckler and
[ __ ] family of roller delayed rifles
submachine guns it's a bit of a reach
but the general more futuristic lines of
this version of the what I guess we're
going to call it the stronger there and
especially especially the straight
magazine straight box magazine do make
me think that they're it's at least a
nod to the G3 which is why I'm waving
about a G3
foreign
just in case you're scratching your head
going what's he talking about this looks
nothing like a G3 when we go into our
first person view we have very H and K
diopter style sites although the drum
which I assume does turn on this in
theory is on its Close Quarter battle
u-shaped Notch it's not on its true
diopter aperture setting for longer
distance but it's counted forward the
housing is very similar the front hooded
site post is is pure HK and if you
squint the silhouette is is not too far
off a G3
foreign
this is an unusual Beast the magazine on
the side kind of says fg42 as does the
overall sort of profile I suppose but it
is bolt action we've got a fluted bolt
there which is not something that well
it's quite a recent development in
Precision rifles as far as I know case
ejection is also a bit strange so the
cases just kind of float out parallel
whereas the way cases are extracted and
ejected inevitably imparts a spin to
them there's no other real way to do it
you have to have a claw of some sort
that pulls the cartridge out and then
something that it hits or perhaps an
ejector plunger on the face of the bolt
that gives Force to the other side of
the case head and it twists the case out
of the gun in this case it's very
obvious because they come out very
slowly and obviously with a manually
operated gun like this bolt action they
will tend to come out more slowly but
they won't just go they'll just float
out gracefully
foreign
standpoint I'm no engineer I'm not sure
how you'd get that big heavy scope to
automatically flip up and down like that
the hybrid Scopes that you'll have seen
with pivoting mounts they rely on you to
physically overcome spring pressure or
detent or press a catch sometimes as
well and rock them out of the way some
are spring-loaded so if you press a
catch they flick out the way for quick
switching to your reflex side what they
don't do is quickly flick the other way
because you'd need a system of linkages
and springs and maybe even a motor to
get that to work so that's just kind of
magic it's also not great for
maintaining zero magnifiers rocking in
and out of the way is one thing because
they they just have to be between your
eye and the magnifying scope but an
actual magnifying optic pivoting in and
out of your line of sight really not a
good idea because every time that shifts
there's a potential for your point of
impact shifting so your bullet doesn't
go away your site says it will not a
good day if that happens
culture
right traditional ish side by side 12
gauge double barrel sorry shotgun I
don't know what that weird bolt lever on
the side is for we have a top brake
lever conventional side acting top lever
at the back there some pretty sci-fi
lines to this thing despite being I
believe 1940s set and then when we break
it open doesn't seem to require any
catches pressing they seem to be taking
break open very literally so we
literally break the gun open over our
knee practically shove into two rounds
doomslayer style and flick the gun shut
in a very cool fashion there's a
whacking great military style sling
swivel on the left hand side of this
which doesn't really jibe very well with
either what this is or those sort of
deeply engraved or in relief uh leaves
on the breaches which are very
decorative which again is at odds with
the very harsh lines of this gun it
doesn't look like an aesthetically
pleasing Sporting gun and actually the
the barrels look to have been made in as
a unit instead of being two separate
round barrels attached together with a
rib across the top this looks to be a
solid oval bit of Steel that's been
bored out
all right this is one I've not seen
before on account of it being in a game
I haven't played yet right away that
design of folding wire butt stock
attached at the bottom of the pistol
grip and the top of the receiver and the
general sort of shape of it and the
German nature of the game says Walther
MPL to me but in as with all the other
guns in the game in detail it's really
very different from from that intriguing
design it's actually mark mp61 on the
side which I guess gives us an idea that
this was an early 60s parallel universe
design I guess to complement the assault
rifle I don't know what the big thing on
the side is it looks like a sort of Vape
machine or something I don't know what
that would do this is a conventional
cartridge firing gun I don't know why it
would need a smoke stack or whatever the
heck that is on the side of the gun it
makes it way thicker than it needs to be
way heavier quite unbalanced and if it
was real as well
foreign
I do like the the moment taken to fold
the stock shut to put the gun away or or
is it to transition to the dual wield
I'm not sure if it's both one or both
either way yeah it's cool that you get
you see that done rather than just
cutting straight to the um in this case
straight to the dual wheel the Stock's
folded which you could easily have done
a little bit of attention to detail
[Music]
okay what the Jesus is going on here uh
I should remember this but I don't we've
got two Luger toggle actions that don't
seem to move unless I'm blacking out
periodically at this point we've then
got a magazine on the side with what
looks like rounds but the rounds don't
move and we have an opening top cover
like a light machine gun but this is
clearly meant to be an automatic shotgun
moving to The New Colossus we've got a
very different take on an auto shotgun
albeit with a very similar feed set up
we've got a lot more detail on on the
case heads that I can see on the right
hand side here so we might get some some
more interesting stuff going on there
I've already seen three spinning barrels
there quite an intriguing looking design
very different lines on it it still has
the Luger cues but really they're really
minimized uh right to the point of just
being design cues of the two cocking
ears let's have a look
and as if to answer my my confusion over
the previous version of the gun with the
non-moving double Luger toggle locks
this gun does in fact have a toggle
mechanism even though it's somewhat
disguised and it actually works it
actually flips up like a like the uh
proverbial knee joints as we often
describe this so it's a
Luger shotgun
with Gatling barrels
[Music]
wow that that is impressive I have to
admit the dual wield on the auto
shotguns seeing the feeds that the
cartridges feed up and around albeit not
clear how they're making it into the gun
because there's no spring following them
they don't appear to be belted and then
so the gun isn't dragging them through
but it looks cool as does the cocking
mechanism and the spinning barrels and
the whole thing really this is quite an
upgrade I think over the previous
version
now this one's fun this is this is a
mounted gun I don't know if there's a
handheld version of it if there is I'm
about to find out definite mg42
inspiration the general shape the top
cover the sort of side saddle belt box
or this this my function as a magazine
not clear but then the rotating barrels
on the front which um Parks back to
Wolfenstein 3D and the chain gun I think
it was already called at that time which
is incorrect
yep sure enough we can Dismount this
thing and use it as essentially a modern
form of the original chain gun from
Wolfenstein 3D which is what I would
hope was hoping was the case got 7.62
millimeters written on the ammunition
device feed device now I have adopted a
strange voice because there's no real
reason why this would be in 7.62 7.62 by
51 that is clearly a reference to 762
NATO and there is zero reason why NATO
would exist in this timeline they would
almost certainly have carried on using
7.92 by 57 Mauser no real reason not to
at least not for me not for machine guns
looking at that spinning Barrel cluster
they're not normal not normal barrels
because you don't touch that part of a
gun and especially if you're going to
try and carry it around you wouldn't
want the extra weight of barrel shrouds
which are there to either to support the
barrel as in the md-42s case and to
protect the other user from the heat
also in the mg42's case they do they do
both jobs here they are there to hark
back to the mg42 so we've got this
Gatling version of the mg42 essentially
they don't really do anything because
you'd be mad to pick it up by the
rotating barrels anyway they just add
weight complexity and cost but how else
are you going to do a Gatling mg42 if
you don't put mg42 Barrel shrouds around
the barrels so various guns in these
games that have lumps and bumps on them
that don't make much sense in this case
I think the big cylindrical thing in
front of the magazine slash belt drum is
probably meant to be a motor yeah so I
think it would make sense you know the
the if you look at the minigun that has
a very Hefty motor on the side of it
that runs parallel to the barrels I
think this is meant to evoke that look
even if they're not thinking about what
Motive Power is actually spinning those
barrels you need electricity to run
these things
okay another one I've forgotten about so
we've got a very chunky very busy
designation Marksman rifle with bipod
legs on top of the gun we've got a
Picatinny type rail there which is a bit
of a head scratcher this supposed time
frame especially given that that was
invented in America weird glowy lights
on the underside of the flip over sight
which doesn't even seem to fit that
picatinny rail all very strange it's a
pretty far removed from a firearm of any
kind really it looks a little bit more
sci-fi than anything else I've looked at
I think
come on
okay either I've gone insane or this
thing has suddenly become a plasma rifle
yeah I don't know how that works but uh
we now are firing blue bolts of energy
and charging the gun up rather than
changing the magazine kind of I
personally prefer if if that was done as
a separate weapon or some kind of
visible visible conversion maybe I've
missed something but the thing about
converting a firearm to a directed
energy weapon is well it's essentially
like converting a water pistol into a
machine gun you know you've got all some
of the same basic ergonomics but that's
it nothing else is going to be carried
over to the finished gun
please do if you can come and visit us
here at the Royal armories one of our
three sites check out the website or
social media you'll definitely want to
if you haven't seen it already check out
our own YouTube channel which includes a
series with me looking at various
interesting firearms in any case we'll
see you again here next week
[Music]